bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuto questo
video sono fa vj e oggi siamo in uno
blog
la settimana scorsa non è uscito ho
rischiato la morte e ricomincia ragazzi
cosa che ho lasciato il momento no
scazzo sto dicendo che stavo già alla
fine io sono avanti nel futuro
incredibile prima di cominciare ragazzi
consente di partire una frenata
settimana che questa settimana è stata
vinta da flavia che ha fatto allora
questo è un di questo è veramente figo
che ha messo una cagata pazzesca
soprattutto la mia faccia se non poco la
di silvio dell'era glaciale è una cosa
che deve assolutamente far vedere e m
bellissi questo è un disegno che ha
fatto laura questo è c'è non è la cosa
più romantica che abbiate mai visto
devi partire col blog prima di finire
nel trash intanto ci siamo già dentro ma
chi è bello ragazzi quando salto un blog
poi c'è un miliardo di cose da dire un
cazzone verso qualcosa da dire prima
news era più semplice volevo
ringraziarvi semplicemente coloro che mi
hanno fatto gli auguri perché ho
compiuto vent'anni non si direbbe questo
bel faccino abbia vent'anni perché li
porto bene
vabbè ho passato il compleanno in
compagnia dei miei amici ho fatto dei
video in compagnia dei miei amici dei
video che non dovrebbe vedere mai
nessuno compresa mia madre però deciso
di metterli nel blog di mezzo tra un
minuto esatto voglio prima dirvi che
allora dalla prossima settimana sono a
marrakech perché per il film ci
trasferiamo a marrakech perché dobbiamo
farle riprese quindi farò video da lì
sarà non so che connessione ci sarà
marra che non lo so se non lo so se
posso caricare video tranquillamento se
devo darli con la chiavetta un beduino
che va col cammello a caricarli al pozzo
quindi spero di riuscire a caricare
video tranquillamente sarà un po più
incasinata la cosa ma cercano
tranquillità di far uscire video si
spera che vada tutto bene
come ultima news ragazzone non vi ta
pazzesca allora prima che io avevo fatto
uscire il fa vidi spalle ho creato il fa
vi risponde tipo due anni fa ho deciso a
distanza di due anni di aprire una nuova
rubrica tipo tipo fa vi risponde che si
ama cazzeggio time è una roba che non
avete voi non sapete che cos'è perché
non ve lo voglio spoilerare
vedrete tra pochissimo sarà una serie
pazzesca creando una delle migliori
forze mi divertirò un casinò a farla
comunque vedrete più avanti
volevo solo annunciarla perché vedete
che parte una nuova serie così a cazzo
non capisce nessuno perché sento queste
ragazzine che siamo arrivati al momento
dei video dei video che ho fatto al mio
compleanno
avevamo bevuto io non bevo tranne quella
volta cazzo per la mia festa per i
vent'anni mi amici hanno portato le due
o tre bottiglie in non bevo io non non
bevete ragazzi veramente cosa siccome
non serve
inutile quasi quanto il fumo siccome
c'erano i pasticcini a festa un
pochettino mi sono lasciato andare e
abbiamo fatto anche mi hanno fatto non
abbiamo fatto dei videopost serata in
pigiama che non dovrei mettere però li
metto lo stesso perché c'è allora faber
[ __ ] tutto godetevi sta roba
[Musica]
tutti
cresce dentro la società
[Applauso]
[Musica]
sicura grande prova
perché io in realtà ho vent'anni ma nel
cuore neo 12 forse neanche i video
andavano commemorati perché cazzo cos'è
cosa che sto roma rimarrà su internet
per sempre porca [ __ ]
chiudo la parentesi docete v come me che
sono buttate a terra i cd che tra
l'altro sono a posto adesso è che non
sono che perché magari con ragazza li ho
raccolti tranquillo ultima cosa ragazzi
previsto ho scoperto che da casa dal
terrazzo di casa mia si può volendo
salire sul tetto della casa proprio e
quindi mentre salivo sul tetto ho fatto
uno scherzo a chi mi stava riprendendo
facendo credere che io stessi cadendo
dal tetto la reazione è stata questa la
rima con ragazzi del duo mazzone che
possiamo passare a fare risponde mi sono
l'umiliante abbastanza tanto lo faccio
in tutti i blog quindi [ __ ]
dignità minchia la prima domanda arriva
da bbm music fi risponde se hai fare gli
editing benissimo come ha imparato
grazie grazie innanzitutto grazie
non è vero me la carico però non è che
allora io non faccio effetti speciali
avatar non faccio editing normale però
quelle di keane che faccio lo faccio da
tipo 4 anni e quindi niente ho imparato
da solo sempre facendo le stesse cose
alla fine sono diventato abbastanza
veloce nel farle veloce un cazzo perché
per fare un video cimento 56 ore però
ascoltare pru meno altro ma cos'è
ascolta resta altro che eminem bernardi
a dirlo forte ma per fare italiani
edificio in bocca
poi lo sport esami ma deve fare poi
quando sei un degno sostituto di jane
prova un suo pezzo e affermati come
nuovo membro di one direction ok
[Musica]
i'd like i'm like
io
[Musica]
stanno aspettando gli one direction ha
contribuito a harry arrivi senti hai
visto sono pronto se il cazzo prima di
concludere devi passare alla favi
domanda di oggi che la fa domandare oggi
è viva se faccio tipo una prova di
sopravvivenza in stile bear grylls
appena arrivò a marrakech tipo come
sopravvivere nel deserto non lo so
fatemi sapere se lo volete nei commenti
e lo farò più avanti poi vedrete che
cazzo esce fuori
vabbè ma noi capitoli stabilito ragazzi
fatti sapere se volete salvare i
commenti che così so di non uccida mi
per niente cosa i ragazzi servito è
piaciuto lasciato come mi piace ero
partito così all'inizio le video
vedetevi conto della demenza anche a
pace di facebook come ogni video trovate
nella descrizione sono severi si stima
flash è una bella ragazza